[Applause]
another milestone in the earthquake
recovery process was celebrated this
morning in Kyoto with the ceremonial
handover of regeneration land from the
crown to the Waimakariri district
council antique Oaxaca or to high Tata
trust the Minister for greater
Christchurch regeneration the Honorable
Megan woods acknowledged the importance
of the occasion to our local communities
this is about land going back to local
ownership with communities being fully
in power of the future of what happens
in their community and I think that is
something that everybody in Canterbury
will celebrate the land divestment will
see 70 hectares of formerly red zoned
residential land and Chaya poi moved
into the ownership of council and five
hectares in the pines beach and Kai
rocky transferred to the trust this will
allow the projects in the woma Kadir its
own recovery plan to proceed and the
minister noted the extensive community
involvement in the plan and praised the
resilience of the local people where can
the regeneration areas has already begun
with the community establishment of a
food forest and a new roading Lincoln
that East close to completion with the
recent approval of regeneration funding
in the council's long-term plan most
recreational projects are expected to be
completed in the next two to three years
we've put eighteen million dollars over
several years for regeneration areas of
carboy and it's all going forward now
along with the work we're doing on the
riverbank right this very minute
other projects include a dog park BMX
track sports fields mahegger chi and
heritage areas and following today's
ceremony the next few years we'll see
exciting progress for the y Mecca DD
district
[Music]